una victoria para la administración byd
en el senado de los eeuu aprobó un
paquete de 430 mil millones de dólares
para combatir el cambio climático y
reducir el precio de los medicamentos
entre otros objetivos con un congreso
dividido el proyecto de ley pasó gracias
a la aprobación de la vicepresidenta del
país y presidenta del senado los votos
positivos son 50 los negativos son 50 el
senado está dividido en partes iguales
la vicepresidenta vota afirmativamente y
se aprueba el proyecto de ley en su
forma en me nada
para los demócratas este logro
representa un punto a favor para las
elecciones de medio término del 8 de
noviembre se espera que el viernes se
vote en la cámara de representantes para
que inmediatamente pase al despacho de
joe biden para su firma
el mandatario no tardó en reaccionar hoy
los demócratas del senado votaron para
reducir el costo de los medicamentos
recetados el seguro de la salud y la
energía al tiempo que reducen el déficit
y hacen que las corporaciones más ricas
paguen su parte justa el líder de la
minoría republicana mitch mcconnell
criticó el proyecto los demócratas han
demostrado una y otra vez que
simplemente no les importan las
prioridades de la familia de clase media
sólo el 18 por ciento de los
estadounidenses están contentos con esta
economía dirigida por demócratas la
legislación ayudará a eeuu a cumplir su
promesa de reducir a la mitad la emisión
de gases de efecto invernadero para el
2030 y reducirá los costos de los
medicamentos para el gobierno los
empleadores y los pacientes